Daemon here with IGN News.
Psy's hit 2012 single "Gangnam Style" has amassed so many views on YouTube that it,...
...well, broke YouTube.
That is, it exceeded the maximum view counter.
According to Youtube, the technology behind its view counter couldn't keep up...
...with the popularity of the pop song.
Quote, "We never thought a video would be watched in numbers greater than a 32-bit integer,..."
"...but that was before we met Psy."
"Gangnam Style has been viewed so many times we had to upgrade to a 64-bit integer."
The "Gangnam Style" YouTube video currently features an Easter egg...
...if you hover over the video's view counter.
When the YouTube video breaks the new 9.2 quintillion limit,...
...we'll be sure to let you know.
I hope it involves cats.
For more weird news from the Internet, stay tuned on IGN.